of all of the economic stories we've
reported in the past few years this one
is the one that has lasted the longest
and affected the most people the squeeze
or cost of living crisis now as you can
see over the past few years over the
past five years we've had inflation
outpacing wages you can see here
inflation the red line wages the blue
line and the upshot of this is that in
real terms people have got poorer but
now wages excluding bonuses are rising
at an annual rate of 1.3 you can see it
here over on the far side here 1.3
percent compared with inflation which is
down at 1.2 not a lot of difference but
nonetheless it is above their first time
in five years and today bank of england
also forecast that in the coming months
inflation is going to fall further
perhaps even beneath one percent so the
squeeze could really be at an end the
bank of england governor would also have
to send a letter of vaccination to the
chancellor it also said by the way that
growth uh this year will remain
comfortably above three percent
although it could drop to 2.9 percent
next year which is a little lower uh
than previously expected that came as
official figures showed unemployment has
fallen by another 115 000 to 1.96
million that's a rate of six percent by
the way that's encouraging news for the
bank
what we are seeing
is encouraging signs in the labor market
encouraging signs with respect to pay we
are seeing the start of real pay growth
this is consistent with our forecasts
from earlier this year consider
absolutely consistent with our forecast
in august we expect this to this pickup
to accelerate um i think our underlying
assumption uh for 2015 is average weekly
earnings growing a little above three
percent
so with inflation running around one
percent one and a half percent that's
real real wage growth but you know
one swallow doesn't make a summer i mean
with this this this has to persist for
the uh for the recovery to be durable
but are people really feeling the
recovery shadow chancellor ed balls says
there's not much yet to cheer about
the idea that people in britain are
going to be celebrating when for month
after month over four years they have
become worse off and worse off and worse
off as prices have gone up faster than
wages come on um it's much too early to
say it's over it's a real living
experience for most people today in our
country worrying about rising bills
having to have part-time work or wages
which have not kept pace with prices for
year after year
so the big risk is that this strong
growth is going to be undermined by
weakness from europe
for while britain's economy and just
look at here here grew by 0.8 in the
second quarter of the year you can see
that germany that shrank by 0.2 percent
france that essentially stagnated north
percent growth italy down by 0.2 as well
spain actually one of the few bright
spots and those euro crisis countries
are doing relatively well 0.6
in spain we'll learn whether germany
europe's powerhouse is in recession on
friday